what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today
I will be breaking down everything we
know so far about the Akuma in black
clover and all of their different forms
powers and abilities the Akuma are also
known as either demons or Devils
depending on the translation
personally I prefer using demons because
that's the same term used in other anime
that we cover here on the channel
including the seven deadly sins and
demon slayer so I just use demon but if
you prefer devil then that is totally
fine with me
along with discussing the various powers
forms and abilities of demons in black
clover I will also be ranking all the
known demons from weak as the strongest
based on the information that we have so
far that isn't to say that certain
demons like say Asta's demon won't
become stronger over time or that they
don't have hidden potential that we
still haven't seen but for this video I
have to go by the information that is
currently available if you enjoyed the
black clover content on this channel and
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know we will do
our best although unfortunately black
clover is a frequent target for fall
strikes and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications stay tuned until
the end of this video because I will be
showing some appreciation for all the
awesome artists who helped bring black
clover fan art and panels to life on the
Internet and finally this video will
include manga spoilers because I will be
talking about everything we know so far
about the demons so please proceed with
caution you have been warned the demons
are an ancient race of extremely
powerful magical beings demons appear to
have some physical similarities to each
other such as horns sharp teeth and
giant dark wings but these features also
appear to vary greatly from demon to
demon the demons actually come from
another dimension so they are not
originally from the main world in black
clover during a conversation with Noel
back in chapter 222 Dorothy Unsworth
that under normal circumstances demons
cannot manifest into this world since
they are from another dimension they
should not be appearing in this world
unless something is seriously wrong in
the past certain mages were able to use
forbidden magic to make a deal with the
devil in order to get more power if a
mage is willing to sacrifice something
and make a contract in order to get
power from the demons they are able to
break the barrier that separates this
world from the world of the demons
according to Dorothy at the current
point in the story the barrier between
the demon world and the normal world is
not as strong as it once was
and it is clear that more demonic power
has been infiltrating the non demon
world when they do manage to infiltrate
this world demons are able to possess
the bodies of other creatures such as
humans and elves and they're also able
to possess certain objects such as a
five leaf grimoire however we don't know
anything about the demon world itself or
why the demons from that world would
want to travel to this dimension in the
first place but regardless of how and
why demons choose to enter this world it
is clear that they possess incredibly
strong and rare otherworldly powers such
as kotodama magic and anti magic the
demons are intrinsically linked to
forbidden magic so let's talk about
forbidden magic and its significance in
Chapter two two one Charlotte implies
that forbidden magic gets its power from
the alternate dimension where the demons
reside forbidden magic interferes with
the nature of the world and the very
nature of life for example the curse
that was supposed to activate when
Charlotte turned eighteen was going to
forcibly change the form of her soul and
the nature of her magic and there was no
one in the kingdom who knew how to break
the curse but Yami eventually managed to
do it by stealing Charlotte's heart
there are multiple other examples of
forbidden magic being used over the
course of the series including lick two
using forbidden magic to turn himself
into the giant demon
sacré using forbidden magic in order to
temporarily seal away the kotodama demon
the kotodama demon himself using
forbidden magic in order to activate
reincarnation magic on the elves before
we get into breaking down and ranking
all the known demons let's talk about
all the forms and powers that we've seen
in the series that are directly related
to demon magic after the elf massacre
Elect was able to use forbidden magic
and the magic stones in order to
transform himself into what looked like
a giant demon and this form is also
sometimes referred to as the demon God
in this form lick became a mindless
monster bent on destruction and he was
ultimately killed by Lumiere the first
wizard king it is worth noting that the
reason lick turned himself into a
monster was to stop the devil from
taking control of his body taking on
this form and being killed by Lumiere
was the only way to stop the devil from
incarnated into this world this is
because in order to fully manifest into
this world and attain their full power
demons must obtain both a physical body
and a 5-leaf grimoire we also have the
Dark Elf form because creatures who have
been brought back to life through
forbidden reincarnation magic are
stricken with wicked hearts their
negative emotions are amplified and
their personalities are more susceptible
to such negative feelings as despair
hatred and jealousy when an elf who has
been reincarnated becomes fully corrupt
by these negative emotions he transforms
into a dark elf so far the only known
example of a dark elf was Patri after he
learned the truth about the kotodama
demons manipulation of him and his
emotions in this form
Patri skin became darker his light magic
became demon light magic which is a dark
version of light magic and the whites of
his eyes turned black in the dark elf
form Patri seems to just be driven by
mindless destruction and he doesn't
appear to have any emotion or remorse
which is similar to lifts giant demon
form however hasta is able to get
through to poetry after his anti magic
allows hasta to enter Patras mind after
that poetry appears to revert back to
his normal form although his left eye
remains black while the other eye
goes back to normal finally because she
used forbidden magic in order to seal
away the kotodama demon sacré manifested
to demonic horns on her head and of
course hasta takes on demonic features
when he uses the black hasta
transformation keeping all of these
examples in mind it is clear that using
any type of magic connected to a demon
including forbidden magic disrupts the
nature of the world and using demonic
magic has significant physical effects
for the user and now let's talk about
all the known demons themselves first up
we have austin's demon the demon who
lives inside of Asta's 5-leaf grimoire
and whose unique demonic power is anti
magic thanks to the demon inside his
grimoire hasta is able to use anti magic
in order to nullify other forms of magic
in fact it is so effective that anyone
who tries to use anti magic will
instantly have their own magic nullified
so the only person who is able to use
anti magic effectively is asta because
he doesn't have any magic to begin with
we know that the demon with Anastas
grimoire began possessing it at some
point after it became a five leaf
grimoire and that is the point at which
it stopped being licked grimoire since
before that moment it had actually
belonged to licked this same grimoire
then became Auster's grimoire after it
chose him some five hundred years later
we know that the demon inside the five
leaf grimoire is able to communicate
with hasta inside his mind and during
haces battle with dark elf poetry we
learned that the demon as the power to
allow asta to infiltrate the mind of
someone else read their memories and
communicate with them directly inside
their own mind during his fight with la
dros asta engages in an internal battle
with the demon inside his grimoire the
demon offers to defeat la rose for hasta
if only hasta would allow the demon to
take control of his body the demon says
that he has been waiting for a chance to
take possession of a physical body and
that he intends to take Asta's but asta
manages to stay in control and the demon
remains inside the grimoire hasta is
thus able to stay himself while still
using the demon's anti magic abilities
in fact as the most recent chapters of
the manga have shown and especially
after the six-month time skip through
immense training hasta is learning to
control the anti magic more and more
effectively and as a result he is
getting stronger and stronger during the
battle with the kotodama devil or demon
however you want to call him austin's
demon spoke to the other demon directly
the kotodama demon confirmed that Asta's
demon is from the same alternate
dimension as he is but the kotodama
demon also implied that Auster's demon
was a lower ranked demon than he is he
basically told us does demon to stay in
his place and to show respect to a high
ranked demon like him for his part
austin's demon did refer to the kotodama
demon as his senior or senpai but i'm
not sure if that was a serious statement
or if he was just mocking the kotodama
demon with that said from the
interaction between the two demons and
the kotodama demons implication that he
is a higher ranked demon and also from
the fact that in order to defeat the
kotodama demon astha needed the help of
lumière Licht and all the elves Yami you
know and so many others we can assume
that Auster's demon is not quite as
strong as the kotodama demon at least
not at this point in the story it is
quite possible that Auster's demon's
future potential is higher than the
kotodama demons or that Auster's demon
if he succeeded in actually possessing a
physical body himself instead of relying
on hasta would be significantly stronger
than he is now however based on the
limited information that we have at this
time I have to place the kotodama demon
above Asta's demon in terms of strength
so with that in mind next let's talk
about the kotodama demon and his unique
power as his name suggests this creature
uses kotodama magic which is a type of
magic that allows him to alter physical
reality with his words he can summon
everything from otherworldly monsters to
swords and all sorts of other magical
and non magical weapons by just
mentioning them verbally and he can also
manipulate a wide variety of objects and
even living beings at will as we have
seen throughout the story the kotodama
demon is a master manipulator so this
unique otherworldly power
suits him well one of the limitations of
kotodama magic is that the user can't
simply command another living being to
die but other than that this power is
pretty incredible and ridiculously
overpowered most magic from this world
has little to no effect on the kotodama
demon the only exceptions are Yami's
dark magic and of course aust as anti
magic but anti magic is also a type of
power that comes from a demon and
therefore from the alternate dimension
as mentioned earlier based on the
information we have so far in the story
I have to place the kotodama demon above
Asta's demon his strength the sheer
number of all pea warriors that were
required to come together to defeat the
kotodama demon and the demon's own feats
place him above us as demon for now but
Asta's demon certainly has the potential
to become stronger in the near future
and finally the strongest demon that we
are met so far is the newest arch
villain of the series the demon who
controls the entire Spade kingdom and
who goes by the name Meggie Kula now it
is true that as of right now we don't
have a lot of information about Meggie
Kula but I am ranking him as the
strongest demon that we have met thus
far for the following reasons
first of all from a narrative
perspective it would make sense that as
the story goes on and all the main
characters get stronger the villains
will also get stronger if Mikiko is
built up as this next major villain and
it turns out that Auster's demon can
just wreck him on his own the build up
will have been incredibly anticlimactic
second the ruler of the Hart kingdom
Laura Pacheco also known as beaver girl
stated outright in Chapter two to eight
that she believes that Meggie Kula is
stronger than the kotodama demon and
finally Meggie Kula seems to have the
special ability which allows him to
drain the mana of everyone in the spade
Kingdom and repurpose the power for his
own ends
moreover Meggie cool appears to be
allowing multiple people to use part of
his demon power at once without him
needing to actually directly possess
their bodies judging by the power of the
dark triad the current rulers of the
spade kingdom who seem to be getting
their strength directly from a key Kula
it is safe to assume that McGillis power
is unlike anything we've seen before
or xenon alone was able to defeat an
entire Diamond Kingdom army by himself
with incredible ease and he turned out
to be so strong that even Luck voltea
himself was scared of him
assuming that xenon is only using a
fraction of McGhee colas true powers
since other members of the Spade ruling
elite have also been using McGillis
power at the same time it isn't hard to
imagine that at full power mcgee kula
would be an absolute monster when it
comes to overall strength we can't
forget that mcgee cola is said to have
killed the insanely strong aussie a
silva with one of his curses and he was
also able to place a deadly curse on
beaver girl I still have a sneaking
suspicion that hacia Silva isn't really
dead but even so
McGee Cola is in my opinion the
strongest demon or devil that we have
met up to this point in the story but
let me know what you guys think do you
agree with my rankings and is there
anything I forgot about the demons that
you would have liked to see mentioned in
this video overall we still know very
little about the demons their origins
their true intentions and their rare and
otherworldly powers but that lingering
mystery is part of the fun and I can't
wait to learn more about McGee Kula in
particular if you enjoyed this video you
want to see more black clover content on
the channel please leave a like to let
me know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications a big shout out to colored
clovers a dedicated team of artists who
work hard every week to bring the black
horror manga to life by coloring all the
panels the black clover series is still
highly underrated so it's always great
to see such dedicated fans and talented
artists working hard I especially want
to single out Yuri and one hooks I
really love these guys I follow their
art every week they are amazing please
show them some love
I will link to their Twitter profiles
down in the description I want to give a
massive thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who support the channel
and make what we do possible with all
the problems on YouTube lately patrons
support means more than ever so thank
you guys so much special thanks to all
of our pro hero tier patrons include
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson Kings Eldred fitty
dolla beat Anatole kazansky alpha do on
hell crews and team Sparky 65 and I
can't forget the ones who rise above all
other clans a huge thank you to all of
our the one tier patrons including in
grata alone Adam
Matty Mac makoto-kun the world stealers
the school bus and Tyson Queenie no if
you enjoy our content and you feel we
provide value for you please consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]